[موسيقى]
نحن في وزاره الطاقه والبنيه التحتيه
معنيين في موضوع
الاستراتيجيات على مستوى الاتحادي لدوله
الامارات من ضمنها اكيد مساهمتنا في
استراتيجيه الحياه المناخي 20
استراتيجيات الهيدروجين والى اخره لكن
اليوم نحن في القمه العالميه للحكومات
اطلقنا اول مؤسسه بحثيه فكريه على مستوى
الشرق الاوسط تعنى بالتنقل الذكي اهميه
هذه المؤسسه البحثيه الفكريه ان اليوم نحن
عندنا في قطاع النقل وما يتعلق في موضوع
الانبعاثات الكربونيه مساهمه القطاع
تتجاوز 22% وهي تعتبر نسبه مرتفعه جدا
بمقارنه بقطاعات الاخرى
وقعنا اربع مذكرات تفاهم مع جهتين محليات
وشركتين عالميات الهدف منها اليوم ان نحن
نجلس على طاوله واحده نشوف شو هالتحديات
العالميه كيف نحن نقدر نضع حلول عمليه
جذريه سواء كانت على المستوى التشريعات
على مستوى السياسات وهلا كذلك حتى على
مستوى تجربه بعض المشاريع على اساس ان نحن
نشوف شو الصالح منها نستمر فيه ونطوره
واللي
كيف نقدر نحن نتعلم من التجارب الاخرى
الهدف كذلك من المؤسسه البحثيه الفكريه ان
هي ما تعنى اليوم بس فقط في النقل اليوم
نحن على تواصل كذلك مع الجامعات
اهميه تجهيز وتحضير
القيادات الشابه المستقبليه اليوم انا في
محادثات مع جامعات نفكر في تخصص التنقل
الذكي وشو يعني تخصص التنقل الذكي في
العشر سنوات القادمه لان احنا اليوم لازم
نجهز جيل المستقبل ونشتغل مش على البنيه
التحتيه المبنيه كذلك تشتغل على البنيه
التحتيه الرقميه نستعد للمستقبل لان
المستقبل في تسارع اليوم كلنا نسمع عن
الجاك تشات وغيرها ويتم السيارات ذاتيه
القياده فلازم نجهزها الموضوع التشريعات
الخاصه فيه جهز التجارب نجهز الجيل القادم
اللي راح يشتغل فيها باذن